okay it seems that people people I've
met some people who are only happy when
they know the world was going to end I
think there's a guy at a party who
walked up to me and said I hear you're
an astrophysicist if I said yes well
tell me about the end of the world in
the Mayan prediction is that is that
real
he was looking all concerned right right
but kind of intent like a bright-eyed
concerned and I said no it's a hoax
perpetrated by the scientifically
illiterate
on the scientifically under informed
well that's a de Jouy out of any one way
to jet up north exactly he walked away
hunched over like I somehow ruined his
day because the world was not going to
come to an end in the way he had
imagined it let's put some facts on the
table
the Mayans had a calendar and the
calendar cycled and they had a but short
count site but the short count calendar
to Long Count calendar the Long Count
calendar restarts basically the end of
December this year people studying the
Mayan calendar after the fact not the
Mayan scholars by the way but people are
kind of amateur ancient culture study
years okay they were sure that because
the Mayan calendar restarts that that
would correspond with the end of the
world and they knew the Mayans had
technology and science and they knew
they had some kind of technological
abilities and then asserted that the
Mayans had deep insight into the future
of the world that even modern-day
astrophysicists do not that the Mayans
know that the world is going to come to
an end and he goes on December 21st the
Sun the earth and the center of the
galaxy aligned and that alignment means
kaput we're all done well if you don't
know physics yeah you might be prone to
say that but you know physics physics
101 you can calculate the force of
gravity the extra force of gravity that
there's a this would render on earth and
you can show that it's ignore ibly
insignificant but then you might think
well maybe it's just a little bit you
need to be the tipping point right for
that want to go bad and are just sort of
hell there with the tiniest of force and
you just need a little bit to tip well
all right if you're a scientifically
literate what you do next is say how
often does that happen
by the way science literacy is not what
you know it's how does your brain wired
for asking questions okay so someone
says the world's going to come to end on
December 21st because of this alignment
just ask how often does it order it
aligns every year that's a boy oh really
so where were you last year exactly you
know so so when you study how the actual
universe works you're in a position to
then inoculate yourself against the
charlatans out there who would have you
believe the world would end and as a
result want you to join their cult or to
hand them money or here's what you do
test how strongly they believe it on
December 20th say I please sign up over
all of your assets into my name right
then see how comforts they look exactly
look because they all needed the world's
not going to be here you know I said I'm
a test right there it's a good test